what's really beautiful is when somebody
used to use a gift for evil and then
uses it for good and I really don't know
what God gave me this ability to because
whether you like me or you hate me
people do have an ability to listen to
me and I do whether you like me or you
hate me you know I I am talented and I
am good at what I do and you know the
haters can say what they want but you
know I have an ability to impact people
that a lot of people really don't and
that's a gift and it's a gift from God
and I don't really know what he put me
on here to do but but I genuinely feel
there are gifts you can use for good and
there are gifts that you can use for
evil and the most gifted and talented
people in society have a responsibility
to use them for good